yeah you know it's funny because your
character of course is is so
sort of intense and brooding on the show
that you're one of the guys that i
actually find a little intimidating i'm
not sure do you know what i mean i find
you in person at first i know that's a
part you're playing but do you find that
you can actually use that on people if
they're bothering you or if they're
bugging you they're bugging you a little
bit too much you can you can use some of
that dr benton attitude i don't know you
know i think a lot of times people have
these preconceptions of you you know
particularly if you play a certain
character but you know when you're in
private you know if you're out and you
just want to uh just you know have a
little privacy if you know someone's
trying to get an autograph or something
you do want to kind of keep them at a
distance but i don't know i mean i don't
i don't buy into that you know right
quite honestly see i wish i could pull
that because i play this guy on tv
when i'm you know when i'm anywhere
people i can't pull attitude on anybody
or give them like a cold stare because
they start laughing when i do that
now um your name i'm sorry i'm sorry
there's a strange man staring at you
where the hell is that
what is that
i don't know who the guy on the left is
the guy on the right is sunny and uh
what's up sonny how are you doing
sorry it's our big sweep stunt you know
or just random people you'll get used to
it all right
okay he has actually the best seat in
the house you know
we're gonna try and get him to take you
with him when you go
now um you changed your name what what
is when you were born it was eric with a
c and then you changed it to eric with a
q yes
so so what did you do that for
you know it's just one of those uh
stupid things when you're you're 18
you're in college uh someone tells you
to do something right uh you know we had
a person that come to our school and
speak and he was you know always saying
how you have to be different you know uh
this industry they'll they'll tear up
your resumes and they won't remember you
you've got to stand out you've got to
stand out so i came up with this this
brilliant
brilliant thing yeah right eric eric for
the queue
you know i i almost did that too
i was i would be quoted
late night was floating
you know they may still do it they're
really responding to it yeah when my
when my show is when i'm off the show
and this is cancer we can do a when this
is cancelled all right you know
years from now years remember
he meant years from now years from now
20 years we got eight more to go now
eric and cronin yeah we could tour the
country um
now there's i don't know if this is true
but it actually you're uh you know you
you have this you have this persona from
the show which i mentioned which is
intense and sort of uh sort of brooding
but i've heard on the set you actually
like to have a lot of fun and that you
you carry a whoopee cushion around or
you did for a while to play pranks on
the set no our first year you know
everyone was uh sort of you know i guess
establishing themselves and i was you
know i'd do a few little pranks here and
there
but then clooney came in
as far as you know showing us what a
prank was he's the master he's the
master he is he's the master we had a
director
who came on and was you know very very
cocky and very arrogant and uh he was
eating some a plate of spaghetti and he
told clooney he said it smells funny can
you smell this for me and so clooney
smelled it and he pushed it in his face
which
wasn't really imaginative funny that's
funny and stupid and stupid and risky
yeah so
all of us are going you know what's
going to happen because you know george
had a reputation of really really you
know playing pranks right so he's going
to get this guy he's going to get this
guy back so everyone's wondering and
waiting
the whole week he's he's just great you
know no problem
the last day of this director's uh shoot
he's leaving we all go outside and
everyone's waving goodbye
as he's driving off
the frame around his license plate
said honk if you eat
and george is just waving
[Laughter]
it was his wife's car
[Applause]
sunny does not approve
she was like i thought that this was a
g-rated show what the hell are you doing
now uh you've been you've been doing
some directing yeah yeah you're doing
some directing and you just directed uh
an episode of soul food the show
actually i directed the uh the pilot of
soul food uh for showtime and uh
it was a cool experience you know there
were a lot of things that i i wanted to
to try as a director and uh when i read
the pilot there was a really hot scene
that i you know i wanted to because that
could be a steamy show you know it can
be yeah and and the great thing about uh
directing a pilot is you set the pace
you set the tone of the show and and how
far it should go and what the style is
going to be so i i saw that as a
challenge and you know i wanted to it
was very important to me because i think
that there's a lack of and a dearth of
uh
positive black sexuality on television
so you know it was an opportunity to
sure you know to do something so i i
leaped at it and uh you know i had a
great time with it i mean it was really
it was you know working with the people
it was pretty cool but um see i don't
know if i could direct a love scene you
know what i mean i don't think i could
be on the set
i i i can't be around nudity uh
but no i think i would be i think i
would be i wouldn't i mean it's just a
real confidence to be out there and to
be controlling a lot you know a steamy
cable love scene yeah i mean it you know
it was it was my first so uh
i mean you know i i made my mistakes but
uh you know
what kind of mistakes are we talking
about here no it's uh but it was i i
found it to be uh i i think the thing
about sex scenes or love scenes or
whatever you want to call them um you
know they're working when the crew is
really quiet you know uh when people are
sort of responding to it when people are
getting turned on they tend to be very
quiet except for you i'm sure yeah i
know
i actually shriek i'm getting turned on
very loudly and start clapping
just been havoc for my single life
no but it was you know it was actually
it was a it was it was a pretty cool
experience and and just you know
having the opportunity like i said to
you know to to explore that uh the the
the erotic zone or you know whatever
that is just you know just playing with
things and you know just you know 400
pound grips behind you breathing heavy
kind of scares you but you know
yeah you're directing a scene and a guy
right behind you
[Music]
i swear i'm having deja vu because it's
like it's like sunny was there looking
through a glass
hey sonny sonny is loving the steamy
parts he's fogging up the glass um
i don't know if i would have sunny
standing behind me if i was this other
guy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
very nice
well
you know it's been uh it was really nice
you to come by oh yeah and we love
having you here uh er of course is on
nbc thursday nights at 10
um and uh congratulations on everything
oh thank you very cool
[Applause]